[Music]
people normally don't eat the decoration
what's up guys i'm brenda and you know
what i am obsessed with chinese culture
and especially chinese food only issue
though is that what i thought was
authentic chinese sweet and sour pork is
actually an interpretation to please the
masses outside of china that's crazy i
can't live with interpretations i want
to see the real thing i want to touch it
i want to eat it i want to learn how to
make it at home that would be like life
goals right there so i started annoying
everyone like hey anyone knows about an
authentic version of sweet and sour pork
then this kid alvin he's like yo i know
about tan suli g it's a kind of sweet
and sour pork so i'm like oh so there
are many he's like yeah but go ahead and
try this all i have to do is find a
place where i can actually eat it inga
god bless this girl she comes to the
rescue and she's like look i got this
place called little pepper it's on the
other side of the world i'm thinking
we're going to china she's like no we're
going to queens
so i'm not with alan and inga in a car
going to college point i don't think
they have trains out here this thing is
one hour and a half away
as far as i know we're back in my
country
so we get there little pepper is huge
and then we meet chef juan
choi uh
hong kong
um
from the area of sichuan in china and
it's going to be late it's going to be
popping you're going to love it and i'm
like i'm down
[Music]
don juan takes us to the kitchen and i'm
seeing a very similar process there's
cornstarch sugar but the way he cuts the
meat is very different it's like little
strips like this like my tiny little
finger not those squares that we're used
to seeing in an american sweet and sour
pork then he's telling us that you got
to drop each one of those pieces into
the frying oil one at a time so that
they don't stick to each other one at a
time that's a lot of patience
[Music]
he's making the sauce i don't see
ketchup which is you know it's a huge
part of the sweden sour pork here in the
united states
he's like so in america and chinese food
is very sweet but like it's sichuan
cuisine every single dish is different
there's so many elements it's not just
sugar
this man is cool with some black vinegar
there's white pepper ginger
i don't know about this kitchen smells
so
good
so now he's putting that dish together
and i'm not seeing though the peppers or
sometimes the pineapple that you would
normally put on sweet and sour pork but
instead it has this vegetables cucumber
beautifully decorated in the plate it
looked amazing so i remember chef juan
coming our way we're just so excited
because you know it's going to be
awesome
[Music]
yes this looks amazing first of all the
decoration is so unfreaking cool so
let's do this
this is nothing like what i ever had
here in the united states
the color is so different the sauce is
not as thick when you taste the garlic
you taste the ginger you taste all the
fresh ingredients you put in it the
sweet and sour part of it was so well
balanced that you were still allowed to
taste that super fresh pork chef long
was saying you really do get that crisp
outside and the tender meat on the
inside it's not dry it's really just
like perfect this is delicious yeah i'm
so glad you brought me here anger we're
about to leave and chef huang
comes over with a bunch of other dishes
brenda how you feeling i'm so excited
i'm like god is this the end of the
world do i deserve this am i enough i
don't know guys
there's a version of tan zuliji that
actually has ketchup you know i'm not
gonna leave if he's offering all these
beautiful dishes i sit down respectfully
and eat like a wild beast thank you so
much for having us it was super special
and i can't wait to come back
[Laughter]
so now we're heading back to the office
and of course i'm going to be sharing
everything i have with some of my
friends at
buzzfeed look what my grandpa used to
make a grand ball
oh my god
at this point i'm trying not to cry in
public because i know what tasting
authentic food from your culture feels
like it can make you relieve a whole
page of your life
it's insane so now you know we all cried
together maybe just me by myself in a
bathroom and now i want to learn how to
make it at home because i want to share
that experience with my family is there
a tiny chance that you can show me how
to make oh you want me to teach you how
to make it yes please okay yeah we can
do it yeah yeah of course are you
serious anything for you oh my god
[Music]
all right so i'm going to show you how
to make the classic sweet and sour pork
no fancy garnishes just the plain old
simple how it's made in china i'm
actually going to use a little bit of
ketchup in the one i'm making a little
bit does help bring all the flavors
together we're actually using pork
tenderloin here which is a very prized
cut of meat in china i noticed that you
cut the meat in this tiny little strips
so the whole point of cutting it into
thin strips is to be able to coat them
but also fry them with really nice
texture
so we're adding a lot of the marinade
ingredients giving it a nice toss and
letting it rest in the fridge to really
just help flavor the meat
and now we're going to start making the
batter which really just involves eggs
and corn starch when i went to the
restaurant in china i was finally able
to sort of break down the chef over
there to give him a secret for the
recipe and he was like oh it's just eggs
and corn starch and i was like what
that's crazy
so the goal here is to really beat the
eggs in the cornstarch until they're
really really smooth there's no lumps
and it's really really silky like this
that really helps you get a much even
coat and a much more even fry
[Music]
chinese takeout can be a lot of fried
stuff a lot of sweet stuff but really
authentic chinese cuisine you can see
how much work goes into the ingredient
choice and how much they care about the
balance of flavors so after a nice toss
we're gonna get the oil ready to fry
so we're frying these at a pretty high
heat these meat strips are pretty thin
so i would say around 350 375 with your
standard make sure you don't overcrowd
the pan as you can really get you know
soggy if you have too much in there at
the same time and what you're looking
for is a really really really nice kind
of light golden brown point at this
stage like damn look at that one
that's a pretty boy right there
[Music]
now we're gonna make the sauce so the
sauce consists of garlic and really just
a lot of you know liquids and spices and
seasonings that we use in asian culture
such as sesame oil or a little bit of
ketchup or some soy sauce
to make the sauce thick you actually
have to add what we call a corn starch
slurry which is very common in stir
fries which is just a little bit of corn
starch mixed with a little bit of water
to help really thicken up the sauce to
give it that signature shine that's the
beauty right there look at that color
that's beautiful
this this actually means quite a lot to
me because every time i would go back to
china to visit my grandpa he would
always take me to this restaurant and we
would order a bunch of fancy things but
somehow his favorite dish on the entire
menu out of all the elegantly prepared
and plated dishes was the tang tsuliji
he was like oh it's so crispy it's so
juicy it tastes so good oh eat it eat it
try it try it and i was like this is
pretty good so the more he said it then
why i began to like it
i think some of the biggest things i
learned from this journey was that tan
suleji it's insanely delicious and that
you know there's really cool people out
there like chef huang inga and alvin who
will do anything to make sure that you
experience their culture because it
means so much to them
[Music]